[Musique]
au pied de l'arc de triomphe un convoi
qui bloquent plusieurs voix des
automobilistes et motocyclistes sont
venus d'un peu partout au pays avec
différentes revendications à faire
entendre
[Musique]
des protestataires qui ont ignoré
l'interdiction manifester décrétée par
les autorités les forces de l'ordre très
présentes n'ont pas ménagé les moyens
pour les disperser des véhicules
remorqués et des policiers anti émeutes
déployés des gaz lacrymogènes ont aussi
été tiré touchant même les clients de
café avoisinants c'est sans compter les
efforts des autorités pour empêcher les
convois d'entrer dans paris depuis
vendredi dans la périphérie des
véhicules sont contrôlés les
manifestants interpellés la
détermination des forces de sécurité
intérieure et entière le niveau de
mobilisation est significative
la préfecture de police n'hésite pas à
rappeler les sanctions liées à cette
manifestation entre aviles circulation
est passible de 4500 euros d'amande et
de deux ans d'emprisonnement
ç'a super bien sûr ça fait peur mais il
ya des priorités dans la vie est plus
que l'argent plus que confort
des coups d'éclat sporadiques dans une
capitale où à plusieurs endroits la vie
quotidienne n'a pas été paralysé
mais une frustration bien réelle de
nombreux citoyens dans un contexte
politique sensible
[Musique]
ce parisien qui espéraient saluer
certains manifestants rappelle que
l'élection présidentielle approche à
grands pas la suite et
c'est dans trois mois ou dans deux mois
dans les urnes après paris certains
participants à ces convois d'un autre
objectif il souhaite se rendre à
bruxelles le 10 où ils pourraient être
rejoints par des manifestants venus
d'ailleurs en europe les autorités
belges ont elles aussi déjà annoncé que
la manifestation allait être interdite
ici rappelle me violer radio canada à
paris